this is a United States Drug Enforcement
Agency we are ordering you to land
- lets land my name is Barry seal that's
for the damage for your sister
hey little darling and you're back
somebody's [ __ ] really happened you
never saw me
out of your class in Civil Air Patrol
pilot like you shouldn't be flying
busted awesome I am
welcome to Bakersfield haven't you ever
wanted something more Barry you should
be serving your country
Dookie hey we need you to deliver stuff
for us all this is legal if you're doing
it for the good guys Wow
very seals a goddamn genius you are a
girl on palette berry that's how you
support this family is it gonna be good
for us how regal you trust me oh we're
expanding operations berry
[Music]
Roscoe dug this up in the backyard their
build blown around everywhere I'll rake
it up in the morning money launching
y'all know it caddies have more trunk
space than any other car I get each and
every one of you to cap your troubles
I'm gonna walk out of here
- I already damn thing anybody you can
do about it hey wait a minute boys
should have taken a cat
I was working for the CIA the DEA and
Pablo Escobar leukemia so skin loose
that's 15 is the owner kilos are in one
go get it done
[Music]
you